bonjour à tous bienvenue dans europe
hebdo votre rendez vous d'actualité
européenne ici au parlement dans cette
émission nous allons nous pencher sur un
débat sensible israël la palestine et
les rapports qu'entretiennent ces deux
pays avec l'union européenne avant de
nous pencher sur la décision
controversée de la commission de
l'étiquetage des produits issus des
colonies israéliennes en territoire
palestinien
direction ramallah en cisjordanie
l'union européenne est le plus grand
pourvoyeur de fonds de l'autorité
palestinienne
nous avons voulu savoir comment ces
fonds étaient utilisés
reportage de jérôme rabier
en cisjordanie il y a deux types de
ville celle administrée par l'autorité
palestinienne comme ramallah
centre politique et économique et celle
où c'est l'onu qui subvient aux besoins
de la population
le camp de réfugiés de jannah zone en
est un exemple
créée en 1948 pour accueillir les
palestiniens chassés du territoire
conquis par israël
il est encore en place et s'est
transformé en véritable ville ici vous
avez une superficie de 250 kilomètres
carrés à l'origine le camp était prévu
pour deux mille personnes désormais nous
sommes plus de 16000 à vivre ici et si
vous regardez les bâtiments chaque étage
représente une génération
et tout cela s'est construit de manière
anarchique l'unrae agences des nations
unies dédiée aux réfugiés palestiniens
est doté d'un budget de 1,2 milliard
d'euros annuels pour gérer 57 camps
comme celui ci plus de 40 % de cette
somme provient de l'union européenne une
enveloppe à peine suffisante face à
l'explosion démographique à l'origine en
1948 et ensuite l'europe loués nus et
les associations humanitaires
fournissent est quasiment tous
l'électricité l'eau et tout le reste il
prenant en charge environ 60% des
besoins du camp mais désormais les aides
diminuent ils ne fournissent plus de
médicaments et plein d'autres choses
depuis la création de l'autorité
palestinienne maintenant ils ne prennent
en charge que 20% des besoins
ils ne financent plus que les écoles et
le nettoyage des rues
une aide humanitaire provisoire qui
s'éternise mais pour l'union européenne
l'objectif principal reste la
construction d'un futur état palestinien
autonome
comme le prévoient les accords d'oslo
signés en 1993
pour cela l'europe accompagne l'autorité
palestinienne notamment dans la
formation de ses forces de sécurité dans
cette école de police ce matin
cet entraînement en situation
si des forcenés qui ne s'arrête pas lors
d'un barrage routier sous l'oeil
attentif du formateur de paul cops
il est dingue
c'est une police qui est très jeune 1
elle a été créée en 1994
on est parti vraiment de très bonnes la
phase où nous situer en maintenant eh
bien on est aux affinage on commence à
atteindre un niveau de police de
standards européens
et c'est ce qu'on recherche et surtout
pour qu'ils puissent après développer sa
part le même et acquérir une autonomie
totale et complète la mission forme
désormais également des magistrats
police et justice
deux piliers essentiels d'un futur état
palestinien
le chef de la mission se félicite des
progrès accomplis mais mesure aussi le
chemin qu'il reste à faire on fait au
bout de dix ans des services de sécurité
et un service de sécurité en particulier
professionnaliser professionnels éthique
entraîné avec une véritable capacité
opérationnelle qui est reconnue tant par
la partie israélienne que par les
partenaires régionaux et tant que la
mission continuera à faire une
différence dans un cadre politique aussi
difficiles que le nôtre
je pense que la misson subsistera si
cette mission a donné des résultats avec
seulement 50 millions d'euros investis
en dix ans d'autres initiatives menées
par l'europe ou par ses pays membres
n'atteignent pas leur objectif dans ce
camp de bédouin l'école financée par la
france a été démontée par les autorités
israéliennes qui ne veulent aucune
construction dans ces zones proches des
colonies enfin le 21 février au moins
trente camions militaires israéliens
sont venus sur le village ils ont
commencé à démonter et confisqué l'école
financée par la france
ils ont démonté l'établissement pris les
chaises les tableaux et ouvrait ce on a
pourtant le droit de vivre et nos
enfants ont le droit d'étudier
regardez ce qu'il reste des petits bouts
de tuyauterie pourquoi laisser
uniquement cela il aurait pu la prendre
aussi vu ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont tout
pris
la france et l'union européenne ont
protesté mais en vain le jardin
d'enfants voisins construit par l'europe
est lui aussi sous le coup d'un avis de
démolition
mon père est venu s'installer ici en
1950 chasser des territoires israéliens
il n'y avait personne ici
la colonie a été construite en face en
1981 moi je suis palestinien
c'est ma terre ici et je n'en partirai
pas alors qu israël accélère le rythme
de ces destructions
cette situation fait dire à certains que
l'aide de l'union européenne et que de
l'argent jeté dans le désert censé aider
à construire un futur état le soutien
financier ne joue plus son rôle pour cet
ancien ministre palestinien
l'aide de l'union européenne sert
désormais davantage de moyens de
pression sur la palestine une forme de
chantage de l'aide contre un statu quo
politique et sociale dans ces conditions
l'union européenne ferait mieux
d'arrêter les aides et faire pression
sur israël pour avoir un vrai accord
politique
si l'europe s'interroge régulièrement
sur l'utilité de cette aide
elle vient pourtant de débloquer une
nouvelle enveloppe de 252 millions
d'euros
depuis les accords d'oslo ce sont 5 6
milliards d'euros dès d'européennes qui
ont été versés à l'autorité
palestinienne
alors à quoi sert de ces fonds et arrive
t'il vraiment aux populations
palestiniennes et faut-il continuer à
financer l'état palestinien c'est la
question que je vais poser à mes invités
marie christine vergiat bonjour
bienvenue ange et députée européenne
vous êtes élu sous l'étiquette front de
gauche ici au parlement européen
bienvenue à vous à côté de vous charles
enderlin
bonjour bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
auteur franco israélien et vous avez été
pendant près de 30 ans le correspondant
de france télévisions au proche-orient
34 ans exactement ça vient ça absolument
absolument en face de vous il axe franco
bonjour j'ai un venu vous êtes
journaliste et éditorialiste politique
pour la radio judaïca ici à bruxelles
et enfin joël rubinfeld vous êtes le
président de la ligue belge contre
l'antisémitisme bienvenus je précise
avant de démarrer notre débat que
l'ambassade d'israël auprès de l'union
européenne a été contactée pour
participer à cette émission mais celle
ci n'a pas donné suite à notre
invitation alors ma première question
quand on voit cette école financée donc
par l'union européenne qui est détruite
près d'une colonie
cela vous choque et l'europe semble-t-il
n'a pas fait de demande de dédommagement
suite à ces destructions
est ce qu'elles devraient isaac franco
mais vous savez c'est ces structures qui
ont été démolies par les israéliens se
trouvent en zone c depuis les accords du
kenya depuis les accords d'oslo en 93 et
95 la judée samarie que d'aucuns qu'est
la séance du jour denis à dany était
divisé en trois zones la zone hacker
sous juridiction administrative civils
et militaires palestienne pour ce qui
concerne la sécurité la zone b qui
mixtent la zone c qui relève
exclusivement sur les plans civil
administratif et sécuritaires de l'état
d'israël il appartient aux européens qui
souhaitent construire dans la zone c'est
de demander des autorisations de
l'autorité ayant pas fait donc sembler
qui n'ont pas fait marie christine
vergiat finalement s'il n'y a pas de de
droit de construire
peut-être qu'il faut préciser un tout
petit peu les choses d'abord qu'on soit
en zone à enjamber où on sait on est en
territoire qui sont occupés illégalement
on en est dans les ce qui devrait être
l'état de palestine vers lequel nous
militons notamment au parlement européen
pour la reconnaissance totalement et la
position et bien ce sont deux étangs et
ce depuis très longtemps j'allais venir
donc la position officielle de l'union
européenne fait deux états dans les
frontières de 1967
donc dans la zone c nous nous sommes
dans la partie palestinienne de l'accord
de 1967 peut-être faut-il préciser aussi
que si les constructions sont illégales
c'est parce que quatre plus de 98 % des
demandes de permis de construire sont
rejetées par l'autorité israélienne
alors que les colonies israéliennes
elle continue plus que jamais et quelles
sont elles aussi charles enderlin à ce
propos pour quelle raison en fait
l'union européenne pour le coup ne me
demande pas de dédommagement c'est parce
que finalement légalement elle ne peut
pas le faire puisque nous disais à
l'instant les a créés
je ne suis pas dans les arcanes de la
diplomatie européenne
tout ce que je peux vous dire d'abord
c'est que la droite au pouvoir en israël
et les colons de ce secteur ont qualifié
l'ambassadeur européen à tel-aviv
pratiquement de terroristes il ya un
clip qui a couru sur sur sur le web
mais ces constructions qui ont été mises
en place après la destruction des tentes
et de ce que les bédouins avait dans cet
endroit
les israéliens veulent les expulser de
ce secteur pour agrandir justement les
colonies les constructions temporaires
mis en place par l'union européenne
était uniquement à des fins humanitaires
c'est ce que l'union européenne a fait
savoir aux israéliens fut largement
quand on voit les fonds on parle quand
même de un demi milliard d'euros par an
qui vont à l'autorité palestinienne
et quand on voit à quel point
aujourd'hui la solution à deux états
paraît très très éloignées est-ce que là
on ne verse pas ces fonds pour le coup à
fond perdu à cran il n'y a pour
l'instant pas d'autre solution que de
continuer et d'entretenir l'espoir qu'un
jour on arriva à mettre les israéliens
et les palestiniens autour d'une table
pour que ils négocient leur avenir et
leur cohabitation
oui il faut continuer à financer il n'ya
pas d'autre choix
mais il faut faire attention lorsqu'on
finances à l'usagé qui est fait de ces
fonds j'ai ici quelques jets si quelques
chiffres qu'ils ont assez interpellant
faut savoir que déjà en 2003 a eu un
audit du fonds monétaire international
qui a conclu au détournement de 900
millions de dollars par yasser arafat
entre 1995 et en 2000 et un peu plus
tard en 2013 au nom abbas est déjà
devenu président de l'autorité
palestinienne
et bien c'est un audit de yachting
courtes aux auditeurs c'est un organe
européenne en cour des comptes
européenne a conclu à la disparition
12,2 milliards e 1000 euros entre 2008
et 2012
voudriez pour être clair isaac franco
que là on est face à de la corruption de
l'état palestinien
on a une corolla une corruption
endémique je dirais presque constitutive
de l'autorité palestinienne et empêche
d'abord qui favorise qui fabrique du
mécontentement qui fabrique du
ressentiment et ce ressentiment n'est
pas étranger à la popularité du hamas
d'accord j'ai envie de fait vous êtes
d'accord vous diriez que l'autorité
palestinienne est corrompu bien entendu
ça a été reconnue par différentes
différentes
suite à différentes investigations
indépendantes mais il n'ya pas que ça il
ya le détournement de fonds il ya aussi
et on le sent d'ailleurs en europe un
certain agacement et aux états unis plus
encore par rapport à l'argent qui n'est
pas détournée mais qui est utilisé de
manière délictueuse c'est à dire il faut
savoir que parmi les centaines 500
millions d'euros à peu près que l'europe
donne hélas une partie de ces fonds va
au ministère des prisonniers il ya un
ministère des prisonniers qui a été mis
en place qui a un budget d'à peu près 60
millions d'euros par an et ce mystère
des prisonniers n'a qu'un seul objet
c'est de payer de rétribuer de
récompenser les auteurs d'actes
terroristes qui vont commettre des actes
terroristes que ce soit tel aviv à
jérusalem à reims à autre imaginons
qu'il y ait un état étranger qui paye la
famille des frères kwasi de coulibaly de
médine et mouche en fonction du nombre
de personnes qui l'a tué je veux dire ce
serait quelque chose d'extrêmement
choquant et bien c'est ce qui se passe
notamment grâce à la contribution europe
charles enderlin
alors écoutez je ne suis plus
correspondant de france télévisions mais
en tout cas je vois les choses un peu
différemment
le palestinien aujourd'hui et l'être
humain sur le globe terrestre qui reçoit
le plus d'aidé internationale de plus en
plus les donateurs que vous avez cités
considère que c'est de l'argent jeté par
les fenêtres et que là tout cet accord
de
de soutien à l'autorité autonome avec
l'argent qui ne va pas là où vous venez
de le dire
tout cet argent finalement ne sert à
rien donc il faut arrêter c'est
finalement pourquoi ne pas accepter sur
glissières la dissolution de l'autorité
autonome le retour d'israël dans ces
régions vous critiquez abbas et son
gouvernement
et l'ol paie aujourd'hui vous avez
raison abbas à 81 ans est entouré par
une cour byzantine qui cherchent les les
successeurs il en trouve toujours pas
l'armée israélienne s'est d'ailleurs
préparé à la dissolution de l'autorité
autonome et au retour de l'armée
israélienne dans les zones autonomes
mais pourquoi ne pas maintenir un espoir
qui selon vous messieurs de fait
n'existe pas puisque l'autorité
palestinienne est corrompu l'argent et
va au terrorisme l'armée israélienne
d'ailleurs ne n'empêche pas du tout ces
paiements aux familles de ceux que l'on
appelle les terroristes alors marie
christine vergiat juste à l'heure où on
traverse des poly crise en europe et on
voit la crise des réfugiés en grèce en
turquie etc
quand on voit que effectivement l'argent
semble-t-il ne va pas directement
palestiniens est-ce qu'on n'a pas autre
chose de mieux finalement à faire de
ceux de ces fonds moi je voudrais
revenir au point de départ d'une
certaine façon et au respect du droit
international israël ne respecte pas le
droit international israël ne respecte
pas les
les accords de 1967 alors peut-être que
c'est un thé un tonneau des danaïdes
mais moi je reproche à l'union
européenne n'ont pas de trop financer
mais de ne pas faire assez pression sur
le gouvernement israélien pour modifier
modifié la donne et c'est une des
questions que pose le soi-disant
étiquetage des produits alors les
produits israéliens mais qui va plus
loin que ça d'ailleurs mais qui fait
qu'un petit élément alors justement la
transition est toute trouvée puisque ça
faisait partie des sujets qu'on allait
aborder l'étiquetage des produits issus
des colonies israéliennes a été donc
décidé en novembre dernier par la
commission européenne est inutile de
dire que depuis elle fait controverse
rappel des faits avec simon blanc
en novembre dernier la commission
européenne demande 28 états membres
la mise en place de l'étiquetage des
produits issus des colonies israéliennes
des colonies illégales au regard du
droit international
une décision qualifiée de technique par
l'union européenne face aux critiques du
gouvernement israélien qui la
considèrent éminemment politique
un à quatre pour cent des produits
israéliens seraient concernés colère du
premier ministre israélien benyamin
nétanyahou l'étiquetage des produits de
l'état juif par l'union européenne
réveille de sombres souvenirs
l'europe devrait avoir honte même si
l'europe sont défend cipi hotoveli vice
ministre des affaires étrangères ajoute
m excepté disons les choses clairement
c'est purement et simplement boycotter
israël les palestiniens se sont
félicités de cette décision mais l'ont
jugée encore insuffisante
en réponse l'état hébreu a annoncé la
suspension des discussions avec l'union
européenne sur le processus de paix
israélo-palestinien un processus de paix
au point mort
isaac franco alors décisions politiques
ou décision technique
elle est présentée comme une décision
technique oui parce que finalement je
donne juste quelques chiffres 34 seul
tendez ses 154 millions d'euros de
produits sur 30 milliards d'euros d'
échange entre l'union européenne et
israël en termes financiers et en termes
économiques ça ne passe pas très très
lourd au plan symbolique
en revanche c'est beaucoup plus
important alors s'est présentée comme
une mesure technique qui n'est appliquée
que pour ce territoire disputé du reste
parce que pour d'autres territoires
disputés comme la république que turque
de chypre du nord comme le sahara
occidental qui sont également des
territoires discuter au regard du droit
international de telles mesures
d'étiquetage de telles mesures
techniques n'ont pas été prises
c'est plus de la gesticulation pour
montrer la mauvaise humeur mais c'est
une mesure qui a une dimension politique
évidente
à ce propos vous disiez qu'il fallait
peut-être que l'europe hausse le ton est
ce que c'est pas par ce biais là
justement que l'europe hausse le ton
dans le débat oui je pense que là aussi
faut revenir au point de départ
le point de départ c'est l'accord entre
israël et l'union européenne
avaya tarifs préférentiels pour les
produits du territoire israélien ouais
en fait l europe doit notamment bas or
les produits fabriqués dans les colonies
ne sont pas des produits fabriqués sur
le territoire israélien
donc des dons des années voilà depuis
des années discute avec israël pour que
l'origine des produits soient indiquées
sur les produits est comme ça n'a pas
marché
on a mis en place des lignes directrices
en 1900 tas en 2013 pardon qui ont été
mises en application en 2014 et pour que
les choses soient plus claires on a
vient de faire une note interprétative
de l'union européenne donc il n'y a rien
de nouveau
ce n'est pas la première décision
politique c'est la mise en oeuvre des
décisions et je le répète je suis têtu
et je le répète du droit international
les produits dans fabriqués dans les
colonies ne sont pas des produits qu
israéliens
alors pour être clair je vais le rugby
fait quand on voit et c'est ce que marie
christine vergiat nous dire depuis l'été
dernier ait lieu a décidé de ne plus
verser d'argent à des organisations des
institutions qui sont dans les
territoires occupés une directive donc
de juillet 2013 rend inéligibles aux
financements européens
toute entité israélienne qui se situe au
delà des frontières de 67 donc
finalement en quoi est ce que c'est une
décision qui cette fin qui pourraient sa
part
tu es un boycott mais c'est le
marchepied pour le boycott vous dire nul
ne sera dupe là dessus moi je n'ai pas
de problème sur le principe
j'ai pas de problème à ce qu'on lit
belle des produits qui viennent de
territoires contestés
le problème c'est que ce n'est que
concernant l'état juif et c'est là que
ces deux problématiques puisqu'elles
sont sous traitement d'exception et on
sait à quoi ça mène
et je voudrais vous donner deux exemples
un collègue de madame vergiat donc un
élu un maire communiste français jean
claude lefort y rebondit sur justement
ce etc
ces résolutions européenne et sur son
mur facebook l'année passée voilà j'ai
ici son texte jean claude lefort qui est
qui était député communiste du val de
marne qui dit bientôt le ramadan
attention à vos achats ceux ci sont des
feuilles de brick isrélienne regardais
en bas au centre et donc ils appellent
implicitement au boycott de feuilles de
brick qui sont fabriqués en israël en
france pardon à gonesse et il y regarder
au centre c'est le cachet pour dire que
ces produits sont kasher donc on sait
très bien que cela va amener à des
dérives antisémites et on en a un
exemple avec un de vos collègues madame
verge je vous laisserai ce document est
ce que cela s'apparente je vois vraiment
pas le rapport avec la décision de
l'union européenne ont vraiment vraiment
pas alors comment est-ce que c'est perçu
en israël est ce que pour le coup parce
que on sait qu' il ya une forme de de
crainte d'un boycott organisé via
notamment une campagne internationale
qui s'appelle bds boycott
désinvestissement sanctions il ya
quelques mois via donc le ministère des
affaires stratégiques un bureau a été
créé pour contrer en fait ce discours
lui a coûté je crois que d'abord bds
aujourd'hui a très peu d'influencé
quelques succès sont extrêmement
limitées et cela permet effectivement à
la droite israélienne qui est au pouvoir
de dire voyez il s'agit pas des colos
d'imeda boycott total d'israël qui
s'apparente à l'antisionisme à
l'antisémitisme
la gauche israélienne refuse ces
arguments et d'ailleurs en 2011 le
monsieur netanyahou a fait voter un
projet de loi qui interdit en israël
même tout boycott des colonies
un artiste israélien qui refuse d'aller
se présenter dans une colonie ou d'aller
participer à une pièce de théâtre dans
une colonie ne risque effectivement
d'être traduits en justice
du point de vue économique il serait là
désaccord avec tout le monde
les produits des colonies quand il
arrive oui les produits des colonies
quand ils arrivent en europe elles sont
moins chers que sur les rayons des
supermarchés israélien pour moi c'est un
faux problème loupé dans la symbolique
qu'est ce que israël le gouvernement
israélien veut faire avec les
territoires la cisjordanie gaza je vais
aller mais c'est ça la vraie question
alors on peut en discuter je vous
justement je voulais posant cette
question on voit bien que le processus
de paix est totalement bloquée au point
mort donc on l'état est ce que cette
question de l'étiquetage pourra faire
avancer la problématique
isaac franco il ou non et qu'en est il
de ce processus de paix non ça ne fera
pas avancer les choses ça ne fait que
braquer les israéliens et nourrir chez
eux le sentiment que ils sont incompris
et que le monde entier contre eux ce
qu'on a observé à travers l'histoire de
ce jeune état depuis sa création c'est
que israël est prêt à faire des
concessions lorsqu'il se sent confortée
lorsqu'il se sent rassuré non pas
lorsqu'il se sent isolé et c'est le cas
israël est isolé aujourd'hui c'est le
paradigme qui a été adoptée par le
président obama depuis son premier
mandat c'est de faire pression sur
israël qui est un changement de
paradigme complet lorsque vous
interroger la population israélienne et
je vais souffrance en israël pour le
savoir bien sûr il y à une demande de
paix il ya une demande de paix alors
lorsqu'on parle de droit international
je souhaite m'adresser à madame en
particulier puisque à trois reprises
elle a attiré notre attention sur le
respect du droit international et sur ce
que vous avez appelé l'illégalité des
colonies comme vous les avez appelé
langage
oui je sais on ne crée rien rien dans le
droit international n'est venu dire
cette illégalité
à telle enseigne que l'autorité
palestinienne à l'intention de présenter
au conseil de sécurité de résolution qui
dirait de ses implantations qu'elles
sont illégales
ce qui veut dire que tout le temps que
le conseil de sécurité ne l'a pas dit
eh bien on n'a pas encore dit veut dire
que ces implantations ne sont pas
illégale au droit international et ce
n'est pas de répéter ces des territoires
occupés quand même c'est la grille soir
et c'est peut-être aussi des territoires
occupés qu'ils sont colonisées par des
israéliens ne pouvait pas vous pouvez ce
que voulait dire
mais lorsque vous pouvez vous parler de
frontières ce que vous parlez de
frontières nul n'ignore que ce que vous
appelez frontières et puis ligne de
cessez le feu est une ligne de
démarcation qui n'a pas de fonctions
politiques qui n'a pas de caractère
politique et si elle n'a pas de
caractère politique cette ligne de
démarcation de 1949 ou du 4 juin 1967
c'est parce que les arabes s'ils
refusaient parce que reconnaître une
dimension c'est les arabes à cette
frontière
je peux vous éclairer si vous souhaitez
reconnaître une dimension politique à
cette frontière
ça voulait dire reconnaître l'état
distincts des masses hérité de presse
verdien je suis aussi précis possible je
veux dire par là que personne ne peut
prétendre qu'au regard du droit
international
cette ligne de démarcation cette ligne
de cessez le feu et une frontière
politique est alors question marie
christine vergiat comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait relancer ce processus et quelle
est la place de l'europe potentiellement
dans un processus est possible laurent
fabius avant de partir au conseil
constitutionnel a lancé une initiative
pour une conférence internationale dont
acte moi personnellement je pense qu'il
aurait pu y penser plus tôt plutôt que
la veille de son départ pour le conseil
constitutionnel mais la france après le
processus tant mieux d'autant plus qu'il
a été repris par le conseil des affaires
étrangères de l'union européenne
donc si on peut aller là dedans si
l'union européenne mais son poids là
dedans je pense qu'elle peut être utile
parce que pour le moment
depuis 1993 on épargne et israël parce
que israël n'est pas victime elle a un
accord privilégié avec l'union
européenne un accord commercial
privilégié
donc elle n'est absolument pas victime
s'était très bien dit dans le dans le
reportage ça ne concerne qu'une toute
petite partie donc arrêtons de jouer les
victimes parlons sérieusement des choses
sérieuses et dont je redis il ya un
respect du droit international que
l'union européenne demande à israël
d'appliquer alors joël rubinfeld est-ce
que vous pensez que cette décision
d'étiquetage sonne le glas de tout
processus de paix possible
je pense je pense pas la région en a vu
d'autres mais je pense je pense d'abord
que nous quatre ici autour de ces tables
nous espérons tous que rapidement il
aura un dénouement pacifique dans la
région et qu'un jour et bien
palestiniens et israéliens pourront se
lancer des blagues à la figure et non
pas des missiles ou des roquettes
et donc je crois que on est tous
d'accord là dessus mais seulement on a
une analyse différente sur les
responsabilités
identification des responsabilités là
dedans moi je pense que l'europe a un
rôle très particulier à jouer là-dedans
dans la mesure où l'europe est le
principal bailleur de fonds de
l'autorité palestinienne eh bien
l'europe ne doit pas stopper les fonds
elle doit être plus vigilante par
rapport à l'utilisation de ces fonds est
aussi autre chose
cet argent peut être un levier très
important
mais contrairement à madame vergiat on
n'a pas la même cible au niveau des
personnes sûr qu'il faut faire pression
je pense que l'union européenne doit
utiliser ses 500 millions d'euros
annuels qui sont donald korité pas les
siennes pour faire pression sur
l'autorité pas décidé et que l'autorité
palestinienne accepte enfin de se met à
table sans conditions préalables avec
israël pour essayer de trouver une
solution parce que comme vous le dites
la passe pas deux pour le moment les
gouvernements successifs israéliens de
droite de gauche de centre
eh bien il était plus ou moins cela là
c'est charles enderlin vous aurez le mot
de la fin est ce que vous croyez encore
en bonne observateurs de cette question
depuis des années qu'un processus de
paix est possible
écoutez non quatre cent mille israéliens
vivant sur 60% ce que vous appelez la
judée samarie et à jérusalem est
totalement sous contrôle la colonisation
qui se poursuit
une autorité autonome qui est en train
de s'auto dissoudre littéralement est-ce
qu'elle va s'effondrer à la suite d'une
manifestation de palestiniens contre ce
qu'elle représente
est-ce que c'est israël qui va réoccupée
on peut parler du passé de la résolution
242 où va l'argent où va ce si nous
sommes au bord d'une explosion dans la
région
tous les dirigeants européens et
américains le savent et entre
parenthèses aux états unis il ya aussi
un étiquetage des produits des colonies
décidé par obama et vous avez parlé de
l'administration américaine anti
israéliennes jamais l'aide américaine à
israël a été aussi important plan
sécuritaire c'est vrai simple oui
absolument mais cela n'a été aussi
important de la part des américains
opération un plan politique non à telle
enseigne que pour la première fois les
états unis pourraient ne pas exercer
leur droit pour l'instant rien donné
il faut tout simplement passer à autre
chose
arrêter de financer ce processus qui est
complètement bloquée qui ne marche pas
ces fonds à l'origine était destiné à la
création d'un état palestinien
indépendant
ça ne va pas la maintenir un espoir qui
s'effiloche je crois qu'il faut arrêter
chercher autre chose je crois qu'il
faudrait commencer par traiter les
palestiniens comme un peuple mûr à qui
on peut demander des comptes
eh bien écoutez ce sera le mot de la fin
merci à vous d'avoir participé à ce
débat merci à vous de l'avoir suivi bien
entendu vous retrouver la semaine
prochaine ahmed tazir depuis strasbourg
bonne suite de programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires et la rtbf
à bientôt
i